goodbye goodbye oh I meant to like girls
the main focus of this episode it's only
the ending um okay so this is the
library a nice design of a I don't want
to say a world necessarily but
definitely a this very cool location
this library love this spirit this owl I
helped late him I actually have it on
right now what that voice is really cool
I just want to see who played that ow
ah hector's I don't know who it is well
he does really good um I am DBM if you
want to know um but get this very cold
calculating voice but can also be sort
of like I mean you could almost hear a
kindness if it wasn't just so cold it's
just this really nice cold voice and
obviously he feels very betrayed by
people because everybody every human who
comes there only wants knowledge to get
the upper hand on somebody else which is
it again to serve an interesting
commentary I mean they go more into wars
and stuff like that but is there like
yeah since now just just so we'll have
more of an advantage um you know as an
advantage to just live life more
comfortably and does that translate into
doing better than everyone else or
sorting out the we got idea fun stuff so
you got you got them going to this place
trying to figure out how to get a step
up on the fire nation and they discover
the Eclipse that's going to be happening
apparently in a couple months so they
figure this out they try to get out of
there uh it remind me very much serve
like a you know this would be good like
Indiana Jones plot a tree this should
have been Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
um because it's just a cool idea is very
inventive and I love the I love these
foxes
Paulo is just so creative that the
servants would be foxes and they
wouldn't be talking or anything though
that's when there is sort of a Fox wolf
sort of thing so okay I was gonna say
it's like the one thing that didn't
combine two animals but but that did I
still love seeing those I love seeing
what they put together because they
create such as cool world
um and like oh I don't want to make this
another short one because I'm trying to
think what else there was I mean it was
good they created this cool spirit and
the design of this library was wonderful
you know a lot of the angles and the
design of this place it felt very huge
you felt like this was and in just an
enormous place and when they needed to
get a lot of low angle shots of them
escaping or fighting or trying to get
away you felt the size of everything so
I thought that was very effective oh you
know what I will say the UH the
professor guy the guy who is looking for
the library I really like this guy uh it
looks like for now it's just gonna be a
one-time-use character but I really
liked him he was very he was just very
passionate upbeat and just seemed
fascinated by knowledge in general and
just very optimistic on everything on
what he found he sees the avatar he
looks and he asks all these questions
just anything he sees he gets really
excited and I like that I think that's
really cool uh and of course in the end
he stays with the library I hope doesn't
cut his head off or anything I I don't
know that's what they're leading to but
and he would seem happy I guess so um
yeah like that guy sure sounded like
Mickey Rooney a little bit uh sir I had
that voice going but I really enjoyed it
so you know I don't have too much else
so that's about it I'm sorry it's such a
short review but uh yeah ah